prazer meu nome é luiz quinderé eu fui
expulso do colégio
larguei a faculdade não tem o diploma
nem carteira de trabalho
fale-me a primeira empresa com 17 anos
uma empresa de tecnologia um ep a minha
gestão no brasil luis que funcionários
fossem muito dinheiro da empresa
eu gastei 30 mil reais numa fábrica
móvel de reciclagem que eu tinha certeza
que esse revolucionário e que nunca
funcionou
o pior de tudo eu já fui goleiro reserva
do high school music o brasil é difícil
né mas as pessoas nunca falam de seus
fracassos
ela só costumam falar do sucesso das
conquistas
e qual o segredo do sucesso mas os
fracassos porque não falamos que jk
rowling a mãe do harry potter fracassou
12 vezes antes de conseguir escrever seu
primeiro livro sobre o bruxo mas sabemos
que ela foi o primeiro escritor a ficar
bilionário na história né
lembramos do carro a taça da copa do
mundo em 2002 mas pouca gente sabe que
foi acusado oito vezes na peneira do são
paulo nas divisões de base
conhecemos valdisnei um mistério pluto
pateta as partes mas pouca gente sabe
que o autismo e falhou a primeira
empresa de animação falou gomes e que
ainda foi demitido de um jornal por
falta de criatividade
engraçado não e até 0 20 para mim uma
das mulheres mais bonitas do mundo
depois da namorada morte amo tá ela foi
né adianta falar da namorada gastam 10 e
21 das modelos mais famosas do mundo e
mais bonitas do mundo sofria bullying na
escola porque ela era muito alta e muito
magra
diferente do padrão fico imaginando a
galera que fazer bonito com ela como
está hoje em dia né
mas até o new york times já fez uma
matéria com ela falando que ela jamais
seria capa de uma revista por conta do
seu nariz do seu olho pequeno e eu nem
consigo chutar quantas capas de revistas
da líbia já foi né
mas já pensaram que se todos esses
fracassos fossem foram necessários para
as pessoas chegarem onde elas chegaram
eu aprendi muito quando pessoas de
extrema confiança roubar o dinheiro da
empresa ou quando eu faria empresas
tecnologia é claro no primeiro momento
deu muito e eu achei que estava tudo
perdido e nada fazer sentido mas o tempo
é muito sábio e se você olhar para essa
mesma situação por uma outra perspectiva
você tira um aprendizado daquilo ou
mesmo uma oportunidade disfarçada que
pode virar todo aquele jogo mas tanto o
fracasso quando o sucesso são referentes
ao resultado e não o processo que na
minha percepção é mais importante é
claro que tem que ter um foco no
resultado e olhar tem uma meta e tem um
objetivo mas pra mim o mais importante é
você olhar no dia a dia o que eu posso
fazer hoje para chegar àquele objetivo
na qual o seu sonho
você tem feito para chegar no seu sonho
né
não importa se ele seja grande ou
pequeno som sonhos
outro dia estava no aeroporto e vi um
menino fazendo cubo mágico
aí eu fiquei muito impressionado com a
velocidade que ele faz um cubo mágico
esses milênio site que você estão
produzindo esse evento
aí eu falei pô cheguei em casa eu falei
pô vou aprender a fazer cubo mágico vai
comprar em cubo mágico e aos escala de
viciados nas coisas quando eu entro numa
eu entro no momento
aí é o dinheiro mas que acordava cubo
mágico
à época o metrô um cubo mágico que eu
tenho uma leitura pelo cubo mágico em
algumas reuniões que eram mais
tranquilas assim o mágico até o netflix
com a patroa
eu via como mágico e fazer como mágico
ela ficou chateada comigo na verdade
porque ela falou que está dando mais
atenção o cubo mágico do que pra ela
naquela semana
é um pouco verdade eu estava realmente
dedicado a prender o cubo mágico e as
pessoas hoje em dia eu faço com
facilidade
tomara que eu consiga aqui enquanto eu
falo para vocês é é aí as pessoas chegam
para mim e falam eu sempre quis fazer um
cubo mágico
eu posso colocar na verdade você nunca
quis fazer algo mais que você quiser
fazer mais que você faria um cubo mágico
porque qualquer pessoa faz isso não
serve de alento nenhum país e só preciso
dedicação você ficar sete dias 14 dias
fazendo isso você vai aprender
invariavelmente não é talento é esforço
e as pessoas elas têm essa idéia de que
o talento é mais importante que o
esforço eo
quando totalmente disso é uma pessoa
muito talentosa mas sem força não chega
a lugar nenhum
pensa em uma pessoa que nasceu com um
dom
ela tem uma voz angelical
se ela não se esforçar se ela não
estudar se ela não cuidar da voz
ela nunca vai ser uma cantora
profissional de sucesso de novo oh oh oh
oh se o esforço é muito mais importante
do que a determinação a quase vai fechar
aqui pra vocês
se tudo der certo só mais uma
ansiosos é mas vamos lá
é essa a partida estava mais nervoso mas
qual é o seu sonho
você tem feito para chegar nele e pode
não ser um sonho pequeno que nem o cubo
mágico pode ser um sonho enorme maior
eu tenho um sonho de tocar violino
municipal
[Música]
já a a
ah então a gente eu sei que eu tocava no
principal tocar muito melhor do que isso
aqui pra gente eu sei que preciso pelo
menos umas 10 mil horas de prática pra
isso
é por isso há quatro anos atrás eu
comecei a estudar violino né eu estudo
toda semana sim eu sou bem bem dedicado
ao violino e ainda estudam as 6 horas
por dia assim hoje mesmo entre seis e
meia da manhã eu estava estudando
violino e mesmo assim eu ainda sei que
vai faltar um cinco ou dez anos para
chegar num nível do músico que hoje toca
num municipal
mas eu não me importo eu não tenho
pressa
eu acho para você fazer qualquer coisa
grandiosa você precisa de tempo e
determinação e determinação que eu tô
falando não é um dia uma semana um mês
são anos determinação é você olhar a
vida com uma maratona e não uma corrida
de 100 metros mas você qual é o seu
sonho que você tem feito para chegar
mais perto dele
o meu sonho era ser jogador de futebol e
na verdade eu acho que os o mais
talentoso um futebol
eu não posso eu não posso sair desse
negócio redonda aqui se não brincam
comigo então o meu sonho é ser jogador
de futebol
pouca gente sabe mas eu joguei na
divisão de base do botafogo e do
flamengo
eu fui campeão brasileiro universitário
pela puc eu já trabalhei para adidas
para a heineken pra red bull pra uma
enfim um advogado quando eu era mais
novo mas o objetivo principal era ser
jogador de futebol e eu não consegui
fracassei apesar de achar mais talentoso
que o futebol do que com música do que
com cubo mágico do que com gastronomia
que as pessoas acham que eu sou
cozinheiro na verdade um só pé se na
cozinha se fazer brownie tapioca e ovo
um desastre completo nem fica boa tá
pior que o venda
mas apesar de achar que é onde eu tenho
mais talento eu fracassei e um dos
maiores traumas pra falar a verdade
por quê
importa o quanto eu me esforce hoje eu
não vou ser jogador de futebol
profissional
eu perdi o time não tem mais tempo para
isso
é eu acho que essas oportunidades às
vezes passa uma vez na vida só se você
não agarrar estas oportunidades
muitas vezes você não tem mais chance
daquilo eu acho que entendo não tem
muito a ver com isso você agarrar essa
oportunidade pra mim empreendedor é
aquele que olha o mercado e ver uma
oportunidade ali dentro e consegue criar
alguma coisa lhe o mesmo ele cria a sua
própria oportunidade né você vê muito
isso com a internet hoje em dia as
pessoas criando mercados que nem
existiam até então mas é um homem
empreendedorismo amo realmente é o
assunto mais leio que o mais estudo que
eu mais converso
eu já lhe diversas biografias de
personalidades do empreendedorismo
já conversei com algumas fiquei amigo de
outras e sempre tentei achar uma relação
entre todas essas pessoas que tanto
admirava
eu descobri duas coisas eu descobri que
todo mundo fracassou em algum momento da
vida mas poucos falam sobre isso né
e descobri que todo mundo era ou é muito
esforçado muito esforçada e não são os
caras mais inteligentes não são os caras
mais talentosos são os mais esforçados
só chegam mais cedo ou mais tarde são os
que trabalharam muitos domingos e
feriados e ninguém lembra porque não
tinha ninguém vendo tava todo mundo
curtindo o seu domingos ou feriados
mas é o empreendedorismo é muito
glamouroso é principalmente a vida do
empreendedor
eu vejo muito isso comigo as pessoas
virão pra mim acho que minha vida
totalmente diferente dá a vida que eu
vivo
as pessoas acham que eu fico lá sentado
mandando as pessoas viajam pelas bahamas
é o que as pessoas acham
depois de 15 anos de empresa né mas mas
não a vida do empreendedor é muito
difícil eu estava lendo uma pesquisa
outro dia uma pesquisa encomendada pela
paypal realizado pela mãe de mainz
dizendo que 66% dos brasileiros quer
empreender então dois a cada três aqui
da sala querem empreender e eu achei
isso um dado incrível
porque eu acredito que em 2007 a maior
ferramenta de transformação social que
existe
e aí eu fui me aprofundar um pouco mais
nessa pesquisa entender os reais motivos
pelos quais os brasileiros queriam
empreender em primeiro lugar era ganhar
mais gente se vocês querem empreender
porque querem ganhar mais escasso vai
fazer outra coisa porque 70% das
empresas no brasil vão à falência em
menos de cinco anos
então as chances de você perder dinheiro
nos primeiros cinco anos é muito maior
do que você conseguir passar de 5 anos e
aí não necessariamente ganhar dinheiro
você pode vir a ter dinheiro mas sim no
médio longo prazo a cinco 10 15 anos
depende do seu negócio
então esse pensamento de curto prazo não
funciona mais
é a segunda coisa motivos pelos quais os
brasileiros querem empreender é porque
querem trabalhar - a essa eu eu discordo
totalmente ainda fazem parte do
empreendedor é sempre o cara que mais
trabalha ainda mais no início do negócio
e o terceiro é não ter chefe é esse eu
até consigo entender eu acho que quando
você sai do emprego formal e vai
empreender você não tem mais aquela
pessoa aquela pessoa que te cobra você
tem que dar satisfação
mas você passa a ter 300 pessoas que te
cobram que você tem que dar satisfação
também então sejam seus clientes que são
quem pagam suas contas sejam seus
funcionários porque a função do líder é
trabalhar para os seus liderados e não o
oposto como muita gente pensa o governo
o trabalho quase seis meses do ano pra
pra trabalhar com esse meu chefe e aí
fora isso o mas só se os fornecedores e
tantas outras pessoas
para finalizar a gente eu queria me
apresentar de uma maneira um pouco
diferente da que me apresentei no início
é um prazer meu nome é luiz quinderé eu
tenho 29 anos eu fundei o blog do luís
quando tinha 15 na cozinha dos pais
hoje a gente tem duas fábricas quatro
lojas 800 pontos de venda entre rio são
paulo brasília e minas 50 colaboradores
muito engajados seis sócios maravilhosos
eu fui eleito um dos 30 jovens mais
promissores do brasil pela revista
forbes
e eu sou apresentador de um programa de
tv chamado fora da casa
no canal + globosat e além do brasil tem
algumas outras empresas o a indústria
carioca ocupa áudio fone de ouvido
a distribuidora lupi eo pão de queijo
e você qual é o seu sonho
o que você tem feito para chegar mais
perto dele obrigado gente
[Aplausos]
[Música]